WHAT'S HAPPENING OVER HERE?
- PBBT. NOTHING, MAN.
WE'RE JUST TRYING
TO FUNCTION.
- WHOSE WEED IS THAT?
- OHHH, THAT'S...
WE GOT--THAT'S YOUR WEED.
WE ONLY BUY WEED
FROM YOU, BABY.
- YOU THINK I DON'T KNOW
WHAT MY WEED LOOKS LIKE, MAN?
WHAT IS GOING ON HERE?
- UM...
- KARL...
WE HAVE NEEDS, RIGHT?
AND YOU, FRANKLY,
WERE NOT MEETING THOSE NEEDS.
- SO YOU WENT TO A STRANGER
FOR YOUR WEED?
- NO, WE WENT TO A STRANGER
FOR GRASS.
WE'RE CALLING IT GRASS NOW.
- GRASS? WHAT THE HECK
ARE YOU TALK--
WHAT--WHAT IS HE EVEN
TALKING ABOUT?
- IT WAS JUST ONCE, KARL.
[sad piano music]
IT DIDN'T MEAN ANYTHING.
- WERE THEY...
BETTER THAN ME?
- NOT BETTER.
JUST DIFFERENT.
- NO.
SHE'S BETTER.
SHE'S WAY BETTER.
YOU KNOW WHY? 'CAUSE SHE OPENED
MY EYES TO A WORLD OF WEED
THAT I NEVER EVEN KNEW ABOUT
WITH GADGETS AND GIZMOS
AND EDIBLES.
- EDIBLES?
- YEAH.
- WHAT'S THAT?
- DON'T PLAY DUMB.
IT MEANS, LIKE, POT BROWNIES.
- POT BROWNIES? NO, BROWNIES
ARE MADE OUT OF FUDGE, BLAKE.
COME ON.
YOU KNOW THAT.
- WELL, MAYBE THAT'S PART
OF THE PROBLEM, KARL.
YOU EVER THINK
OF THAT, MAN?
- YOU GUYS ARE ACTING CRAZY
RIGHT NOW.
YOU'RE ALL ACTING INSANE.
YOU'RE--YOU'RE SMOKING BROWNIES,
AND YOU'RE EATING WEED?
- IT'S CALLED GRASS NOW!
- OH, YOU WANNA YELL?
LET'S YELL!
- DON'T DO THIS, KARL!
- YOU DID THIS!
NOT ME!
AND WHAT'S FUNNY IS I EVEN FOUND
YOU DUDES A PRESENT,
BECAUSE I WAS THINKING
ABOUT YOU DUDES.
JOE DIRT, MAN.
IN THE DIRT.
FREAKIN' SEE YA.
I HOPE SHE WAS WORTH IT.
BECAUSE YOU THREW AWAY
SOMETHING SPECIAL.
I THOUGHT WE WERE BRAJES.
[phone vibrating]
NOW, IF YOU'LL EXCUSE ME,
I NEED TO TRY AND TAKE
THIS PHONE CALL.
[dog grunting,
phone vibrating]
HELLO?
- HAPPENS WHEN YOU GIVE
AN ANIMAL AN ANIMAL.
GUYS, I KNOW THIS HURTS
RIGHT NOW,
BUT IT'S FOR THE BEST.
- MOMMY, IF YOU CAN HEAR ME,